[Music]
very rarely look in this kind of
proximity but I'm not sexting um ah if
you want to know how to be a good leader
watch Donald Trump and don't do that
don't do any of that I realized recently
that I I do something very close to
prayer and I don't want to show any
disrespect to people by using the word
prayer because I know from my friends
who are religious that prayer has a
supernatural element that people are
actually connecting to a higher power I
don't want to show disrespect to that
but I also want to make a little bit of
an argument
Sam Sam Harris makes his argument for
atheist meditation I'll make a little
bit of an argument for atheist prayer I
do something before I go to sleep at
night called Penn's guilt roundup and
Penn's guilt roundup is I go through
conversations that I've had like tonight
weren't before I go to bed I'll think
should I really have made that sexting
joke when I was at the big thing but I
really have done that was that authentic
people uncomfortable is that online now
run through how I could have done that
better I said it was no joke I'll
actually do that and I run through
conversations I've had and things I've
done one that comes up every night was
you know should I treat tell they're
better and the answer is always no but I
do reflect about it I do think about it
I also try to think of what I want and
how I can get there now I'm very
fortunate because when I go to my
desires they're they're not very often
material material desires because my
family is well cared for I've been I've
been very lucky and I've done well but I
think about I used to think about my
weight and one of the things I used to
and I'm very I'm very hesitant to use
the word because I don't want to show
disrespect for those who think it really
is supernatural but I would pray to be
able to
control the wants of my diet wouldn't be
nice if I didn't want pizza would that
be great and I try to run throughout and
do that and I do believe with God
there's a lot of throwing the baby out
with the bathwater I'm not referring to
baptism there I'm referring to huh
I referring to the fact that so much of
the social and personal elements of
religion are really good I would say
maybe more than good maybe very close to
necessary trying to find ways for people
to get together and help each other and
be in celebration and all over this
country now when I first started talking
openly about atheism the country was set
at about 0.8 percent for atheism 0.8
less than 1 percent and now some polls
are giving you over 20 percent I don't
think that people are being created as
atheist I think they're just simply
coming out of the closet and we have to
show a great deal of gratitude to the
religious people in the u.s. for being
more tolerant of atheists they do dare
to there to come out but I'm watching
now a lot of my friends struggle with
how to get that community in their life
and every community in this country
whether it's the fo Mo's you know the
former Mormons in a Salt Lake City they
call themselves fall Mo's or whether
it's the the community thinkers in the
churches that don't have God that are in
Meadow in Vegas or that the DC chapters
that are doing this stuff I hear about
all of them they try to get together and
do music and do that kind of stuff we're
going to find what that is you know
maybe that already is a rock concert or
something I don't know what it is or
maybe this is you know EDM music you
know or EDM maybe it is that and I just
done just not hip to it but I things are
happening in that but also personally we
have to be very careful let me throw out
talking to God we don't throw out
self-reflection and I also don't think
and I think there's some religious pious
who would disagree with me on this
strongly
but I think it's okay to talk to an
imaginary power if you're sure that
power is imagined there yeah there's
this there's this nutty thing it's like
a Zen koan to me placebos work even we
know they're placebos
that's one hand clapping that's harder
than one hand clapping placebos work
even you know they're placebos do my
weight loss one of the things I did with
Ray Krone eyes cray Ray was to put
myself in a cult I used a lot of the
techniques of a cult in order to get my
weight off I pretended that cray ray had
answers to all my questions any question
I asked cray Everett answer now we knew
in advance he was gonna be making up
stuff but I needed that I needed someone
to give me the answers he also cut me
off from my friends by saying don't talk
about you die to them ever till you lost
your way don't ever talk about it first
rule of cray ray don't talk about cray
ray do this on your own we knew we were
doing that kind of stuff we knew we were
cheating and it worked it worked you
know you can pretend I think sports
people do this all the time they pretend
that winning a game is life and death
situation they know it's not but they
believe it when they're when they're
playing whatever games they play why I
use the sports analogy or I don't know
the rules to one single sport is beyond
me
bad rhetoric that's why I did it um but
I also think there's a lot from prayer
in just self reflection you sit with
yourself I like to do it right before I
go to sleep laying in bed going over how
could today have been better
how can tomorrow be better how can I
make my own life my family's life and
the world just a little better and I'm
not talking about working hard and
busting your ass it would be a hero it's
that much better could I have been more
polite to my barista those are the kind
of things I asked myself at the end of
the day I think that we're going to find
in 20 years that we have pulled
just sucked out of religion all the good
the community the self-reflection the
compassion the love and thrown away the
bad the god the hate the the
superstition at that go away let the
reflection in the community come back in
and I pray you've understood me
[Music]